you shared some stories with me about
being on city council that there was a
that there was one where uh a local
reporter used to show up and then they
stopped showing up and then all of a
sudden things went uh were a little bit
less buttoned up after the the local
press stopped yeah appearing at these
meetings well on the presidential
campaign and on the Merrell campaign you
spoke a lot about the importance of
local journalism and independent
journalism and it was one of the things
that Drew midi back on the presidential
because you know politicians don't often
talk about this topic and and the reason
for that is because
I experienced it you know I was
um the youngest
person on city council by far but I was
also for a lot of the time the only
Democrat
and it just created a lot of scenarios
where
um
sometimes I felt like just stuff wasn't
getting done on the council and like you
were just saying when there was a
reporter there at least one
the meeting was an entirely different
meeting no one here watches their City
Council meetings on TV like their
Spectrum TV or no one watches it online
no one
goes you know uh but if there's someone
reporting on it then
people in the J in the community have a
sometimes a genuine idea of what's
happening or at least if you were one of
the members you'd be much more buttoned
up he was like oh [__] my my stuff could
get recorded exactly so I felt like
whenever
a reporter was there
just more would get done and we'd have
better like conversations about helping
people in our community and the the the
difference was drastic and it just it it
shows me just how important political
accountability is and despite the
experiences that we have had with
certain journalists and certain outlets
and I mean you know well I find local
news to be uh less ideological more up
the middle you know I mean right you
can't really I mean the the void gets
filled unfortunately with cable news and
nationalized uh ideological uh squabbles
and Facebook feeds and the rest of it
um so you know I mean as like you said I
mean we're connected on this but you
were one of the people that let me know
it's like hey it's not made up I mean
this [__] is exactly real life it's so
real it's so real and I mean like kudos
to the
journalists and stations in America that
prioritize their local councils and
governments because I think it makes a
huge difference in what actually gets
done for taxpayers and for voters well
kudos to them if they're still doing it
because I think that the number is that
uh I think something like
um 60 000 journalists lost their job
over the last several years yeah you're
this young Rising Superstar and the
Democratic party
um you get to introduce Bernie at a
rally Upstate right yeah that was
awesome yeah that was sick go Bernie
yeah I mean that like you know I was a
burner in 16 before I ran
um at least I you know I mean I get the
text to prove it we all do we all do
[Music]